I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense when in 2017 when my sponsor
left which you know you've been around
long enough to see why should happen to
me twice I I haven't liked that was a
new problem for me and so you you got
fate like I for the first time was faced
with the scenario of like what if they
what if they just fire me what if you
know especially NASCAR with gigantic
budgets like what if they just let me go
and then I had this rush of feeling of
like I'm not ready and I'm telling you
it felt really good because I didn't
think like that I didn't think like oh
my god I'm excited I'm ready let's do
this so embracing to the Bible right it
was comfortable and and and then it was
right and and and also you know you you
get put in that squeeze position where
you're like what do you feel and I felt
oh [ __ ] I'm not ready and it felt really
good to feel that but here's the problem
it planted a seed and so this is my
experience in retirement anyway but I
planted the seed of like but but like
not just like the idea in a distant way
and not feeling into that because that's
the magic of like feeling into something
like you feel into being successful or
winning or retiring or whatever you have
to like feel the emotions and and
imagine your life without it right so I
started imagining where would I go what
would I do where would I live what would
I you know all these scenarios running
through my head these these like further
scenarios than just the concept of
retiring and I was like man that's not
so bad
but see but that's why I looked at it
you know and I talked I was I'm talking
to you I talked to Michael Andretti I
talked to their junior about it I talked
to Tony Stewart about it just as a as a
casual conversation and I'm not afraid
of that and in in the way I'm not the
type of person that like I just said I'm
like what's next I know I will find
something yeah you know so to me it
still I think you know through the years
when I had you remember when I left and
ready my sponsor left and they fire me
and I had five years into my contract
and I had to go and figure it out so I
went back home to Brazil found a bunch
of sponsors came back and you still
wanted it 3 years later I won the 500
and then I went to Ganassi which it was
a big team and then like you were like a
lot of pressure the champion and I had a
tough tough tough teammate Nixon I mean
and chip and and and the pressure and
the pressure got into me
and and the pressure to perform and and
I think to be honest during those four
years I've thought about retirement
because I was getting beat not just in
the racetrack but mentally and people
are trying wow this is how you got a
drive like Scott Dixon this is the car
Dixon drives fast how can I said guys
let me put it this way if I was able to
just copy what he does then then it
would be easy or anybody anybody
anything it has a good car everybody's
gonna what we're gonna [ __ ] ring
sorry we're gonna free dance where all
you want finish okay thank you
so and that really got into me and so my
last year a Ganassi I told chip in his
face that I I knew I didn't do a good
job for him and then I shouldn't be
there because for some reason it wasn't
clicking and that's when it was what's
next and I'm like do I want to keep
racing or not and then I meet a J and J
is like a JC Saint come on let's let's
build this team so that's my fire so
yeah how did you go it's a new goal it's
a new goal that lasts in the
championship now again the sponsors
getting excited because they're getting
because we're like LeBron in Cleveland
when he came back I wish I wish I hope I
can do that
but it was it is kind of that you know
what I mean like in my mind was like you
know what this is what I want to do and
then I remember because Larry Ford came
to me and says why you in a race from me
mm-hmm you know like you're I mean
you're Tony Kanaan I'm like exactly I'm
just a normal race car driving I want to
make you guys successful so last year
yeah you were there and we let a bunch
elapsed
yeah and the 500 and they were thrilled
so basically that's why I'm doing it so
yes do I love racing
100
and do I feel like you sometimes that
you know man I gotta travel man I got
the hotels and the buses and like I I
have to hey don't forget don't forget
you gotta say ABC my sponsor I was so
bad I had to go to media training after
like I was in IndyCar driver because in
in I have like I'm old enough now that I
can say guys I am NOT doing this yeah I
will plug you guys in but it's not I'm
not gonna start my interview my number
40 car with ABC supply Chevy Firestone
dude story got it in though I'm just
saying that's not happening yeah it's
not my style
yeah I haven't done it in years I think
my fans know I mean I've always you know
it's funny because let's say I've know
I've known you for so long
and then I go see an interview and I'm
like that's that's [ __ ] up that's not
her they are telling her what to do yeah
just to begin the interview after that
you become yourself but you're like yes
my you know Go Daddy yeah come on guys
you know and then everybody's the same
so you're watching that you like really
mad I always felt like they interview me
because I don't do that exactly right
because you're interesting because
you're controversial or because you say
which won't you answer the damn question
and so when you change into the person
to serve your sponsor that just says the
names they're not gonna want to talk to
you anymore so so what now I'm not a
valuable commodity or I don't help help
your bottom line because I'm not on TV
you look at my damn suit so I I mean I
stand you stand your ground don't you
lose that fire
hey I'm 44 I was just dying the more and
more I do it or whatever the hell I want
you know it gets to the point that it's
just not so anyway but that was that's
what gets me going
yeah that's what you know I still want
to do it and and yes I can't assure you
that I don't
probably I don't have more than two
years left yeah I myself and then I keep
telling my friends that too and I will
ask you as well as a friend because it's
hard you know when you see an old person
driving a car on the street and they're
all over the place but God still of
course I see people driving I'm asking
my friends my close friends if you if
I'm doing that on the race car that I'm
not good enough anymore and you guys see
that please pull me aside discreetly and
tell me that
[Music]